There are people in Hollywood called script
supervisors whose job is to make sure that
there aren't any silly or stupid continuity
mistakes in their movie.
And often, they totally fail.
So don't worry if you never picked up on these
cinematic goofs, because here are some big
movie mistakes that everyone failed to notice.
Terminator 3 plane switch
When John and Catherine decide to make an
airborne getaway, they head to a blue and
white Cessna parked in the hangar.
As they enter the plane, the identifying numbers
on the side of the plane read "N3035C."
A subsequent shot of the plane flying over
the arid landscape shows that the plane number
now is "N3973F."
Finally, when they land the plane, the number
switches one more time—back to the original
"N3035C."
Die Another Day's vanishing scar
In this James Bond adventure, Bond-girl Jinx
gets into a sabre fight with Miranda Frost.
At one point during the fight, Jinx takes
a nasty slash to her midsection—splitting
her shirt open and leaving a bleeding shallow
wound.
Later, 007 and Jinx are reveling in the hoard
of diamonds, and he pours a handful across
her stomach—which is completely unblemished
by any scratches or wounds.
Oops!
Harry Potter and the magic shirt
In Harry Potter and the Order of the Phoenix,
Harry has a bad dream after an argument with
Seamus in the Gryffindor common room.
During that dream, Harry is shown thrashing
around in a light blue crew-neck t-shirt.
When he wakes up, he sits up and is wearing
a dark blue button-up Henley shirt.
That Henley actually comes from a later dream
sequence in the film, when Harry is dreaming
about Arthur Weasley in the Department of
Mysteries.
Rocky Horror Picture Show's vanishing jewelry
Eddie has the words "LOVE" and "HATE" tattooed
on his knuckles in Rocky Horror Picture Show,
and his left hand is accessorized with several
rings—including an Iron Cross pinky ring.
Eagle-eyed Rocky Horror fans may notice that
the ring disappears while Eddie plays saxophone,
only to reappear later with no explanation.
Even the rings aren't what they appear in
Rocky Horror!
Terminator 2's magic windshield
In a pivotal scene, the T-1000 commandeers
a helicopter, literally headbutting through
the windshield to gain entry and take control.
This leaves a gaping hole in the shattered
glass.
But later in a zoomed-out shot of the helicopter
pursuing Sarah Connor and the Terminator on
a highway, the windshield is magically fixed.
The magic helicopter gets even crazier after
it somehow explodes, then somehow immediately
repairs itself and then explodes again.
Lord of the Wrists
Merry and Pippin are taken captive by the
Uruk-hai in The Lord of the Rings: The Two
Towers.
“Looks like meat is back on our menu, boys!”
But they manage to escape during a middle-of-the-night
raid by the horselords of Rohan.
The hobbits crawl away from the battle, hindered
by their bound hands.
At one point, however, Pippin is nearly trampled
by a horse, and he rolls on his back and flails
his suddenly-untied hands around in fear.
After the danger of getting stomped underfoot
has passed, he resumes crawling away with
hands tied again, and he and Merry use a blade
to cut through their bonds.
Gladiator tank
During one of Gladiator's big fight sequences,
three different chariots end up flipping over.
Pay close attention to the third chariot as
it lurches sideways and crashes—you can
clearly see a tank of some sort of compressed
gas used in the stunt just hanging out, strapped
to the bottom of the chariot.
“Are you not entertained?
“Are you not entertained?!"
Alien hoodie
Fans of the original Alien may have spotted
one glaring continuity error with the film's
wardrobe.
When the crew is exploring the boneship, Kane
is shown wearing a close-fitting cloth hood
under his space helmet.
He's attacked by a facehugger, and when they
cut his helmet off, the hood is nowhere to
be seen.
Maybe the alien ate it?
“Oh no!
Not again!”
Wizard of Oz slipper switch
Even the most famous props in movie history
were involved in an on-screen screw-up.
Yes, Dorothy's ruby slippers do the disappearing
act during a sequence when she and Scarecrow
get attacked by an apple tree.
Instead, she's wearing a pair of decidedly
non-magical black and tan lace-up saddle shoes.
There's no place like Payless!
Thanks for watching!
Click the Looper icon to subscribe to our
YouTube channel.
Plus check out all this cool stuff we know
you'll love, too!